reality
reality doesn't have to be naturalistic
it doesn't have to be exactly the way
light is you want to create a coherent
world for the audience that they believe
[Music]
the biggest challenge it's like it is
any film though it's just creating a
kind of world that hangs together for
the whole you know entirety of the film
it's the overall look that the biggest
check is the biggest challenge really so
then you get an idea and then you go oh
my god now I'm not gonna do that you
know so then you break it down yeah that
was interesting because you know
obviously it's quite a lot of effects
work involved
Denny Dennis Gassner a production
designer myself we sort of design that
space and the kind of lights that fit on
the wall it's very sort of specific look
and then you you think a challenge that
is such a effects driven of morph in
these two characters together so they're
the same girl the composite girl of the
two okay you think that's an effects
thing and immediately the effects team
we have were saying well we need to
shoot one girl as an element against
blue-screen and you know I was real I
really reacted against that I don't like
working with blue screens because it
changes the kind of feel of the light on
the subject so we shot some tests in a
kind of mock-up lighting situation to
match what the set was going to be and I
said well just do this and see if you
can rotoscope it you know you can
extract the element of the girl and just
do it that so we had it in exactly the
same lighting situation and they did it
and it kind of worked okay and I said
okay let's what we talked about is Denny
let's do it on the set and Denny wanted
to do on the set because he wanted to
match one girl's performance to the
other you know so we would shoot you
know the scene with one of the girls
first then he would get that take that
he liked and then we would reach shoot
it again with the other girl in the same
lighting in the same set at the same
time so about that I think that was a
real benefit not just to the
the look but also to the performance you
know I like to be involved in all that
I'd like to be involved in you know
location scouting and the discussions of
the sets and and there's nothing worse
than getting on a set and finding
looking at the blocking and thinking
well that that wind is too high or you
know how do I do a pan because there's a
wall here you know it's the wrong wrong
set for the scene or something I've
never been in that situation because I
always insist on having a lot of prep
time and being involved very early on
well that was that that was interesting
cuz the house exterior was built on
location outside of London on this
stretch of moorland that's an army
training some sort of reserve kind of
thing and then there was an interior set
that was on stage then when Javier's
from running away from it and they get
to the frozen pond that's yet another
set really but that just was lit with
one big lighting rig so there's a trick
there was to combine all those things
that though it was the same place
funniest thing comes to mind with some
we were shooting an exterior with a real
helicopter and we put this spotlight on
it so it's coming around the house and
we had to shoot at dusk so we only had a
limited amount of talent there hand held
in Javier's here doing his bit and the
helicopter comes down and he looks
around at one point as the wind comes
and his false teeth flew up towards the
camera I'll never forget that it was
just so funny and you know but it was
say it was like it was a wonderful
challenge to do things like that and but
we did shoot some of it like that and
then we shot some model shots as well to
to put the Hep B on the helicopter and
the crash is actually path model and
part model part set you know
[Music]
jarhead was the first film I did with
Sam and just the way that we approach
that was technically very different
because I shot that whole film a
handheld and we didn't really rehearse
until we had the camera I mean I just
started shooting
instead of oil fires we had little
columns of lights and then we we shot an
element of an oil farm pasted it in in
post so the biggest compliment I was
ever paid once was by a cinematographer
of the ASC clubhouse who came up to me
and asked me how long we'd shot in
Kuwait and I said it wasn't Kuwait it
was a universal stage 11 and 12 so I
thought that was that was really neat or
to kind of chuffed it up so you know
that's the great thing about you know
computer technology I don't like effects
I don't like too much CG but there's
certain things you can do you replace
the light with the actual true look of
the source we did it in 1917
[Music]
every time I walk on ice at in the
morning it feels like I've never done it
before let alone on every film but 1917
in particular because I really hadn't
done anything like it before enough your
orders are to deliver a message for
calling off tomorrow morning's attack if
you don't we will lose 60 100 men your
brother among them you get further and
further into a take and it's like six
minutes seven minutes you think oh this
is a really good one and I'm looking at
the sky if the Sun comes out we're
screwed you know so it gets more and
more anxious and it really stressful as
the shot goes on and then when you get
it it's like such a high and but the
thing is you can't you know normally
yeah okay you get something that's
really magic and then you find well that
didn't work there we can cut to a
reverse of a reaction or a wide shot or
whatever you can find a way around it
but we couldn't because everything was
had to be exactly that and it also had
to end in exactly the right way because
we knew that the end of one shot would
then segue into the beginning of the
other one so we had to get the end of
that shot right to match the beginning
of the next one
we had to rehearse before the sets were
laid out I'm in a normal film you might
say oh well we can afford to build two
undefeated trenches and then we'll
double them up and we'll shoot that way
for what you know what I mean you make
it look longer but we couldn't they had
to be of a certain length you know it
all had to be worked out for the shot we
only use one particular camera that's
really nice about cameras right as I get
older they get smaller and lighter it's
kind of good really Arriflex a few years
ago have brought out this large format
camera and so I asked them we asked them
if from if they were ever going to make
a mini version because this the larger
camera we couldn't have dealt with it
with the kind of rigs we were using and
they they thought about it and
eventually said yeah we could provide it
so they guaranteed that they would give
us three prototypes of this camera and
we couldn't have done it without a
camera that lightweight because even if
the rig would have taken it there's the
distances and if the operator was
carrying it as just physically you know
after a color takes you know you need
about 20 operators to do more than ten
takes you have to have relays of
operators which wasn't gonna happen
it's the biggest individual lighting
unit I've kind of creative it was 50
foot high and it was like five tiers of
lights I think you know there was
something like 2,000 1k bulbs
that's all dimmed out to get the right
color what a first thing we did was was
map it out on a model little LEDs to
mimic where the flares were going to go
and we had them on little wires so we
could move them about and then we can
move them in relationship to the
structures so we could tell where the
shadows were basically gonna fall then
we had you know I mimicked the light
with a just a bulb the light of the
church burning church so we could tell
how the shadows of that were going to
fall and we could tell that angle of the
camera as it comes up the street we
didn't want to directly see the church
until we came under the colonnade and
then it was rehearsing the whole thing
with the actor and just that the
choreography of the shot you know a way
before anything was built on the back
lock it's kind of a lot of crap
something like that yeah
the last shot of this film I wanted the
Sun to come out or one particular moment
in this shot and it had been sunny all
day and I was looking at the weather
apps and the clouds were coming but it
might
it was getting dark well it was getting
late in the day I didn't know if the
clouds will come in time and one tiny
little cloud came over it was coming
over the Sun so we called everybody to
start shooting as luck would have it got
to the point I want the Sun come out and
the cloud went and Sun came out and I go
wow I hope that's a good take for Sam
because for me that was perfect it was
take one we did another maybe 25 takes
and he liked that one for performance so
I thought yes
[Music]
the train sequence was interesting
because Andrew said well you can it can
go dark I want that night to be really
dark you know but you never really know
what a director means by that unless you
work with him a long time I mean I
remember doing a silhouette shot once
for the director and I said well I think
we play this scene in silhouette was
quite a long dialogue scene he said oh
yeah yeah sure sure sure
and then we're watching dailies and he
says but I can't see their faces
I mean sort of well it says silhouette I
mean it was fine but you know I mean
there's what is that what he's dark but
thankfully Andrew really meant dark so
it was an interesting technical
challenge because the light on the train
is like a it's a 5k tungsten power which
is quite a beefy lamp for that kind of
situation but we've made a little round
snoop for it and it was on a dimmer when
it's far away it wanted to be bright and
as it came nearer the camera I didn't
want it to flare so we just gradually
dimmed it down as it came in but when we
did the other cuts of the guys in the
woods you know in that their hoods and
that we we had a flat there with a lamp
on it because he couldn't do it the
train because we're actually panning the
light and if you look at it it doesn't
make any sense that the light is going
at like 90 degrees almost to the train
track instead of pointing straight
forwards but nobody noticed no see it
was just a like a concept that just came
from
you know Andrew and I just talking
talking about it and yeah it's great
opportunity I say to create something
that is like a tone poem yeah I mean I
kind of love about movies that we don't
do enough of this it's more than just
dialogue and a story it's emotions are
created by the images and those sound
juxtaposed to the images and I
personally would like to have seen a lot
that long cut was really lovely I mean
not the one that exists isn't you know
it's one of my favorite films I must say
yeah
[Music]
they always create a very different
world each film they do Dan he's great
he's such a fantastic guy and a good
friend and and but he's really searching
for something you know he lifts it
because he's looking for something
really special and he and he's like the
great directors he's like Sam is and
Andrew Dominik you know they're they're
looking for something really special and
if they don't necessarily know exactly
what it is they know it when they see it
you know and so they really kind of push
you Fargo for instance we just done
hudsucker proxy before that which is a
very stylized large canvas and then they
they wanted to do this film kind of a
docudrama in a way and so it shot kind
of slightly longer lenses and it's yeah
it's a bit more observational I suppose
no country was different again as a sort
of bleakness and then it comes from the
book and their script the whole field
and then the other film I think that is
also extremely different
anything else they've done was a man who
wasn't there which is probably one of my
favorites because it's it harks back to
film noir but it's not it's kind of a
modern Noir and it has that kind of
metaphysical quality about it it's so
much about understanding your likes and
dislikes and I'm gonna trust really you
know you know yeah that's really I think
yeah I mean it's for very many reasons
but it's like one of the first films I
would did was 1984 it was Richard
Burton's last film and I was thought he
was in garden when it came to terms of
acting and he's done some you know films
that I loved and actually just to be
working with him and sitting with him at
luncheon lunch time discussing life it
was that special
[Music]
[Music]